well it's uh switch gears now if you're  still shopping online and you want your  gifts to make it by christmas you better  hurry delivery deadlines are quickly  approaching the same is true if you're  sending your own packages the deadline  to ship ground with the postal service  and fedex is tomorrow the cutoff for ups  depends on where you live first class  mail needs to be sent through the post  office by the 17th there are also  pricier options of course for faster  service last chance at the post office  and ups december 24th so fedex has the  same day service uh or actually it was  the 23rd and fedex has the same day  service on the 24th and remember online  retailers will only give you an  estimated delivery time you know that i  just ordered something that had a big  window of time so you should buy now to  make sure it does arrive on time